gott hat aber nehmen sehr viel
bundestagspräsident sehr geehrte
repräsentanten der verfassungsorgane
mitglieder des deutschen bundestages
frau bundeskanzlerin flogen bündeln
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich stehe
vor ihnen als stolze deutsche wie einst
meine großmutter albertine neuland des
seligen angedenkens nicht meinen
großvater drei ihrer deutschen heimat
verbunden hoch angesehen in der
bayreuther kaufmanns gesellschaft
passionierte wagener die anderen
ermordet in theresienstadt im januar
1944 von meiner großmutter habe ich die
liebe zu den menschen geerbt trotz der
menschen stehen als stolzer deutsche vor
ihnen wie einst mein gott heiliger vater
fritz neuland als treuer deutschland hat
die j 1919 zutiefst empört den vertrag
von der sei ein dekorierter veteran des
ersten weltkriegs der für sein deutsches
vaterland an der front gekämpft hatte
seine loyalität
sein eisernes kreuz schützen ihn unter
den nationalsozialisten vor keiner
demütigung nicht vor berufsverbot
enteignung der deportation seiner mutter
der trennung von seiner tochter der
zwangsarbeit
mein vater hat mich liebe zu deutschland
gelehrt
trotzdem am 9 november 1938 hat
deutschland das tor zu auschwitz
aufgestoßen vor den augen der welt unter
dem beifall weiter teile der bevölkerung
die nationalsozialisten hass und
gleichgültigkeit besiegelten das
schicksal von millionen juden in europa
am 27 januar 1945 befreite die rote
armee das vernichtungslager auschwitz
birkenau die gleichgültigkeit nicht der
gewissheit über ein singuläres residenz
loses bis heute kaum vorstellbares
menschheitsverbrechen 76 jahre später
erzähle ich ihnen im bundestag aus
meinem leben einen deutschen gegen ende
oktober 1932 werde ich in münchen
geboren
in der stadt kommt dass nach
jahrhunderten der diskriminierung und
verfolgung erlangte jüdische
selbstbewusst
in drei synagogen zum ausdruck die
meisten deutschen würden sind deutsche
patrioten
sie wollen sich assimilieren wollen
dazugehören
als hitler an die macht kommt den ich
drei monate alt doch auch erwachsene
freunde und bekannten begreifen nicht
die verheerung des tages die gut 500.000
deutschen juden sind zu tief in ihrer
heimat verwurzelt um zu zweifeln über
1600 jahre lebten damals jung auf diesem
boden seit 1871 als gleichberechtigte
staatsbürger und gesetz ist gesetz oder
nicht
als ich vier jahre alte den verletzungs
meine mutter sie war dem druck die welt
indem sie durch konversion und ehe mit
einem juden ausgesetzt war
was blieb war schmerz meine großmutter
sie zu uns sie möchten ihr ein annähernd
normales leben ermöglichen
wir spielen singen lassen
sie lehrt mich die grundlagen unseres
glaubens aber keine bemühung kann über
spielen das leben wird uns juden immer
beschwert
er lasse verbote für entwicklungen
machen den alltag unerträglich eines
nachmittags will ich zum spielen raus im
ruf gegenüber treffe ich mich oft mit
mädchen und jungen aus der nachbarschaft
heute ist das gitter verschlossen ich
rufe sie drehen sich von hinten rand
mich die hausmeisters frau an juden
kinder dürfen hier nicht spiele trennen
schließen die augen zu hause nimmt mich
großmutter auf den schoß sinnlos das
erlebte kleinzureden
sie spricht von finsteren seiten die
bald vergehen würden es ist meine erste
begegnung mit dem anders seiten danach
darf ich nicht mehr allein aus dem haus
die finstere zeit vergeht nicht im jahre
1938 wird immer dunkler
seit dem frühjahr gehe ich auf die
jüdische schule ich hatte nicht so auf
das wären gefragt doch jetzt sitzt die
furcht mit dem klassenzimmer der
schulweg ist ein spießrutenlauf voller
parolen und pöbeleien egal wie stark man
sein will
ausgrenzung und anfeindung hinterlassen
tiefe verletzungen ende der 1930 er ist
die arisierung in vollem gang
systematisch werden die geschäftlichen
und beruflichen jugend jüdischen
existenzen von
sichtbar inmitten der deutschen
gesellschaft unser leben findet nur noch
zu hause statt
aber privatsphäre gibt es nicht mehr
meist abends wenn es dunkel und juden
verboten ist das haus zu verlassen
der sturm männern in langen menschen
mental streichen durch die wohnung als
sei es die ihre porzellan besteck bilder
antiquitäten erleichtern
sie bedienen sich nach belieben und die
tiere akkurat deutschland schikane
bedrohung beleidigung und nicht nur
verbale gewalt sind inzwischen der
übliche umgang mit juden angst
verunsicherung verschlechterung
begleiten jeden gedanken und die bange
frage was passiert als nächstes mal
waren mein vater und ich kurz an die
luft männer springen von einem wagen mit
kommen vater wird mir von der hand
gerissen
eine mir unbekannte griff
dann legt sie an ihren kinderwagen sie
bedeutet nicht ein stück zuhause wartete
ich mit großmutter städtische stunden
später fährt mein vater zurück und wir
hatten noch einmal glück lassen sich sie
essen nicht hier klar sagen wer coruna
maßnahmen mit der
nationalsozialistischen judenpolitik
vergleicht verharmlost den
antisemitischen staats terror und die
shoah das ist
dass es inakzeptabel im juni 1938
besuchte hitler menschen die
hauptsynagoge ist die stimme ins auge
tags darauf ordnete er den abriss an
stahl bender und sprengungen machen dass
garten haben macht das gotteshaus dem
erdboden gleich der november am abend
verlassen weil ich die wohnung keine
zeit für fragen an der hand meines
vaters ihre geschichte straßenlärm war
aufgeräumt aus den fenstern der ogl
jakob synagoge 2s aller zellen justizrat
rothschild opera schädlichen immer
nannte aus seinem haus blut läuft in
übers gesicht
ich darf nicht stehenbleiben nicht
stolpern nicht weinen nur nicht
auffallen
als die wehrmacht in polen einmarschiert
bin ich 7
mit kriegsbeginn stehen die chancen für
juden ihre deutsche heimat zu verlassen
nahe null meinen onkel new york die
linke 2 bürgschaften zu organisieren
zwei großmutter ist nach den united
states bestimmungen zu alt sie will dass
wir den vater nicht würden sie nie
verlassen
thema erledigt ich höre was die menschen
erzählen die zu meinem vater kommen
seitdem die anwaltszulassung entzogen
worden
dieser rechts helfer für ihre mandanten
sie berichten von verwandten dienstag
verschleppt wurden ich verstehe nicht
alles aber ich begreife ist es geht um
leben und tod
mit wenigen habseligkeiten müssen wir in
superbenzin die letzten scheinbare
geborgenheit ist dort seit november 1941
familie aus münchen in richtung osten
darin jüdische münchnerinnen und
münchner allen alters zusammengepfercht
bekannte und freunde verschwinden für
immer mehr und mehr verzweifelte
versuche meinen vater um hilfe
deportation befehle in händen beinen
stehen
ich höre sie noch heute aber vater kann
ihnen nicht helfen niemand kann es und
wir alle wissen es
ich bin als wir informiert werden
ein alten- und kindertransport nach
theresienstadt großmutter oder ich
müssen in den zug
meine starke großmutter trifft
augenblicklich entscheiden
früh am nächsten tag wird vater nicht
weg bringen wird vater mich weg bringen
entschuldigen
in erhoffte sicherheit zuvor
der schwerste moment in meinem leben
großmutter sagt sie gehe zur kur und
komme bald zurück ich habe weiß was das
bedeutet
weil ein klammere ich mich an sie an
liebe zärtlichkeit geborgen hat sie
werden wir lange zeit aus meinem leben
verbannt sein
mein vater bringt mich in einem dorf in
franken
die familie von dem ehemaligen
dienstmädchen meines onkels nimmt mich
als ihr uneheliches kind auf ich muss
mich vom vater verabschieden vielleicht
für immer
ich werde die leute gewöhnen ich am klo
einiger spannung haben wasser für alle
carl zeiss kalte zimmer körperliche
arbeit an angst heimlich und unsagbare
einsamkeit
denn sie ist eine streng religiös
erschlagen
sie war mit gott einen pakt eingegangen
wenn sie mich beschützt werden ihre
brüder teil aus dem blick wiederkehren
so kam es ende mai 1945 war ich mitleid
kalte vor dem kran zum
ein auto hält mein vater steht vor mir
es ist kein unbeschwertes wiedersehen
bis heute einige ich nur welche qualen
sie hinzugefügten seinen hut sein
augenlicht fast gänzlich zerstört aber
er lebt und ich lebe ich will nicht
zurück nach münchen zurück zu den leuten
die uns beleidigt bespuckt und jeder
form gezeigt haben wie sehr sie uns
plötzlich huston aber ich habe keine
wahl
um so begegnete ich ihnen allen
ich will weg aus dieser stadt aus diesem
land mit 16 lerne ich samuel eto'o block
aus polen im ghetto wirken seine mutter
und fünf geschwister ermordet
konzentrationslager blanche erschossen
sie den vater vor seinen augen
er und sein bruder ruben überlebten die
kz blanche und buchenwald und den
todesmarsch den süden am 8 mai 1945
wurden sie befällt
samuel ist die liebe meines lebens wir
kommen zusammen und wünschen uns nichts
sehnlicher als ein neues leben in der
neuen welt für die auswanderung lerne
stangen schneiderei um ein visum zu
erhalten
alle zwei tage suchen wir unseren namen
auf der liste der einreisegenehmigung
ende 1919 151
kommt mein sohn bernd zur welt sobald er
laufen kann soll es losgehen
das heißt wenn du gott zum lassen
bringst dann macht pläne seien louis
missouri das ziel unserer ausreise hat
mich nie gesehen
wir bekamen noch zwei töchter sonja und
er ist im schweigsamen nebeneinander mit
dem nicht jüdischen umfeld versuchte die
jüdische gemeinschaft aus dem über leben
ein leben zu führen ein leben das sechs
millionen zustands schönen brüder
schwestern mütter und väter großeltern
genommen wurde ein leben in trauer und
schmerz im gut einleben in deutschland
aber heimat ist heimat erst in den 60er
und 70er jahren wird das schweigen
durchbrochen auch nicht jüdischer seite
wuchs das bewusstwerden über die
verbrechen der vergangenheit
es wuchs die erkenntnis dass
auseinandersetzung und aufarbeitung
unerlässlich sind wir das bauen der
zukunft
so konnte auf jüdischer seite das
vertrauen wachsen und die neue
bundesrepublik in der es gelang auf den
trümmern der geschichte eine tragfähige
freiheitliche demokratie zu errichten
einen positiven akteur im vereinten
europa in der liberalen
eine staat der die unverbrüchlichen
menschenrechte jeder und jedes einzelnen
wort und verteidigt ich fing an mich zu
engagieren
zunächst sozial in der eigenen buntes
gemeinde und dann immer mehr dafür dass
aus dem nebeneinander ein miteinander
wurde ein gesellschaftlicher kraftakt
wir haben brücken über unüberwindbar
scheinende abgründe gebaut und
beschritten
heute gibt es wieder jüdische gemeinden
im ganzen land oft ein aber sie sind da
und sie bleiben allen rückschlägen zum
trotz neue synagogen wurden gebaut in
meiner heimatstadt bildet das jüdische
gotteshaus wieder eine symbiose mit der
frauenkirche und dem rathaus jüdische
schulen lehrstühle studien werke
sportvereine rabbinerseminar in eine
vielzahl von institutionen vereinen und
gruppierungen zeugen davon
in unserer gesellschaft ist das
pluralistische vitale deutsche judentum
wieder eine anerkannte kraft die
zuwanderung jüdische
kontingentflüchtlinge aus dem
postsowjetischen raum zeigte schließlich
der welt am ende des zwanzigsten jahr
deutschland ist für juden wieder eine
gute mit hoffnungen verbundenen heimat
heute danke ich gott dafür dass ich
daran mitarbeiten darf dem jüdischen
leben in deutschland eine perspektive
auf dauer zu treten
ich danke der großen mehrheit der
menschen in unserem land die sich genau
das wünschen
und ich danke meinen mitstreitern in
politik und gesellschaft die mir dabei
geholfen haben
unbeirrbar mutig und beherzt wir dürfen
stolz sein auf unsere bundesrepublik
verehrte damen und herren aber wir
müssen sie warehouse verteidigen nicht
einen tag dürfen wir vergessen wie
zerbrechlich die kostbaren
errungenschaften der letzten 76 jahres
sind ich muss ihnen nicht die
chronologie antisemitischer vorfälle in
unserem land dagegen
sie erfolgen offen ungeniert beinahe
täglich verschwörungs unten erfahren
immer mehr zuspruch judenfeindliche
denken und reden bringt wieder stimmen
ist wieder salonfähig von der schule bis
zur oma dem und natürlich im internet
dem durchlauferhitzer
hass und hetze werde anwesende 2021
blicken wir auf 1700 jahre zurück in
denen jüdisches leben auf dem boden der
heutigen bundesrepublik dokumentiert ist
ich danke dem bund den ländern und
kommunen für die unterstützung der
initiative zu die zu diesem anlass aber
ich trage schwer daran dass sich in dem
wunsch nach freude und normalität noch
immer die alten ängste und sorgen
mission gemeindemitglieder freunde und
bekannte denken laut nach doch noch
auszuwandern
der starke rückhalt aus der politik ist
wichtig großer dank gilt auch den
sicherheitskräften die die jüdische
gemeinschaft und ihre einrichtungen
schützen
aber es klafft eine lücke zwischen
politischer saison und
gesellschaftlicher realität
zumal einige nicht zu schmerzlichen
analysen bereits sind zweifellos die
größte gefahr für alle in unserem land
war und ist der rechtsextremismus und
natürlich ist radikal rechtes
gedankengut ein wesentlicher träger des
judenhasses auch im linksextremismus ist
antisemitismus tief verwurzelt
hinzugekommen ist der dschihadismus die
fahrt durch den radikal-islamischen
hamas auf unsere lebensart das feindbild
jude symbolisiert den verhassten westen
das moderne das frei so sind juden und
ihre einrichtungen bevorzugte ziele
ihres t
aber das phänomen antisemitismus ist
größer als das offensichtliche der
judenhass an der parcours zu packen
werden muss auch dort zugreifen wo es
wehtut
auch in die mitte der gesellschaft
auch dort wo integration in die
demokratischen werte abgelehnt wird
auch dort wo hinter dem denkmal von
toleranz zu lange intoleranz klären
dürfte auch dort wo eine verbrennung von
antisemitismus als intellektuell
verkauft wird
so wie dort wo man nicht jude sagt
sondern zionist oder andere kurz auch
dort wo der staat israel diffamiert
delegitimiert und mit doppelten
standards verurteilt wird
der kampf gegen antisemitismus ist eine
sisyphos aufgabe aber wer sich nicht an
menschen gewehre vom jüdischen
maschinengewehre von jüdischen
einrichtungen gewinnen möchte muss diese
bewältigen
ich wünsche mir dass eine kippa nicht
bitte geben muss dass eine halskette mit
davidstern solche fans getragen werden
kann wie ein anhänger mit kreuz und ein
makake trikot wie ein fc bayern statt
es geht dabei nicht nur um den schutz
jüdischer menschen
denn wo antisemitismus platz hat kann
jede form von hass um sich greifen
rassismus homophobie frauenfeindlichkeit
menschenverachtung
jeder kollege der kampf dagegen
ich sage kam für die menschenwürde
demokratie für einigkeit für recht und
freiheit
sehr geehrte damen und herren auch in
deutschland erleben wir spaltung
polarisierung aggressive regeln und
persönlichkeit
einige behaupten es gäbe meinungsklima
die nicht missbraucht werden darf
ungeheuerliches sagte zu machen worte
sind die vorstufen von taten wenn die
grenzen der wohngeld der meinungs- und
versammlungsfreiheit abgesteckt werden
sollte der gedanke hinter artikel 18
punkt gesetz mehr beachtung finden
auf keinen fall darf auf dem rücken der
polizei ausgetragen werden das
legislative und judikative liegen lassen
ein persönliches wort zur polizei ich
wurde als kind von männern in deutscher
uniform gedrängt und geschlagen weil ich
den aufenthaltsort meinung des vaters
nicht preisgeben wollte
heute beschützt mich seid ihr an beamte
des polizeipräsidiums münchen mit ihrem
leben im namen meiner familie ich sage
ich hier in wohnhaus danken
meine damen und herren ich hatte meine
heimat verloren
ich habe für sie gekämpft ich habe sie
wieder gewonnen und ich werde sie
verteidigen
ich stehe als deutsche stolze deutsche
vor ihnen
obwohl alles dagegen sprach und noch
immer vieles wirklichen spricht trauer
schmerz verzweiflung und einsamkeit
begleitet mich aber ich weiss unser land
leistet viel damit jüdische menschen
sicher sind und hoffentlich nie wieder
allein
ich bin stolz auf unsere demokratie auch
wenn ich sie mir dass es kein geheimnis
wer auf der wünsche die feinde der
demokratie sind stärker als viele
glauben
ich bin stolz auf die jungen menschen in
unserem land sie sind frei von schuld
was die vergangenheit angeht aber sie
übernehmen verantwortung für heute und
morgen interessiert leidenschaftlich und
mutig verehrte damen und herren ich
stehe vor ihnen als mutter grossmutter
urgrossmutter münchnerin byron deutsche
europäerin jeden als mensch ich bitte
sie hier
passen sie auf unser land diese worte
richtig explizit nicht an die ganze
rechte seite des plenums ich kann nicht
so tun als kümmerte es mich nicht dass
sie hier sitzen
ich spreche sie nicht ausschalten
vielleicht ist die eine oder der andere
noch bereits zu erkennen in welcher
tradition angeknüpft wird zu den übrigen
in ihrer bewegung
sie werden weiter für ihr deutschland
kämpfen und wir werden weiter
unser deutschland kennt
ich sage ihnen sie haben ihren kampf vor
76 jahren verloren der erde tanken
verehrte damen und herren anschließend
noch drei gedanken der erste ich den
millionen opfern wären wir heute
gedenken
sie sind in unseren herzen sie werden
nicht vergessen niemals das zweite gilt
den zeitzeugen
viele haben an diesem pulk von
unfassbaren braun berichtet wir geben
jetzt den stab der erinnerung an sie ab
im vertrauen in ihn in gute hände zu
legen
vergessen sie uns nicht und er das
dritte ich den jungen menschen
es gibt keinen keinen besseren kompakt
als eure herzen
lasst euch von niemandem einreden wir zu
lieben und wenn ihr zu hassen habt gott
schütze unser land an israel stand ihnen
dass sie mir zugehört haben
[Applaus]